well about five years ago the hillary
clinton for president campaign paid a
british spy called christopher steele to
produce a document now known as the
steele dossier
which despite the fact was fraudulent
really hamstrung the trump
administration virtually for the entire
four years that dossier claimed that
russian hackers were operating in the
russian consulate in miami
even though for example there is no
russian consulate in miami among other
false claims the dossier said that
donald trump's former lawyer michael
cohen made secret trips to prague now if
cohen had been to prague he probably
would have said so since he turned on
trump completely but he swore he didn't
most famously the dossier said the
russian possessed a lurid tape that they
were using to blackmail donald trump the
famous p tape
all this was false and yet in a new
documentary christopher steele says
maybe not surprisingly he stands by all
of it
and today do you still believe that that
tape exists i think it probably does but
i wouldn't put 100 certainty on it so
how do you explain if that tape does
indeed exist it hasn't been released
well it hasn't needed to be released why
not
because i think the russians felt they'd
got pretty good value out of
donald trump when he was president of
the us anything you believe you got just
wrong the interview i gave to mother
jones that was a mistake i think so yeah
but not the p tape not michael cohen and
prague
not carter page
none of those things to my mind have
been disproven
totally destroyed carter page's life by
the way the p-tape i've never seen it
nobody knows it exists but it probably
exists because trump sucked up to russia
so much which by the way the
administration sanctioned like eight
times during those the whole thing's
demented
and yet the media seemed intent on
rehabilitating this christopher steele
guy why is that well here's one clue
later in the interview steele warned
that if donald trump runs again he'd be
a threat to national security
he's making moves perhaps trump is to
run again in 2024. do you think if he
runs again he's a threat
to
united states national security to the
national security of the united kingdom
yes potentially
a threat to our national security
this is a country we live in a country
where our national security
establishment sincerely believes or
claims to that russia is the greatest
threat we face anyone who thinks that is
by definition a threat to our actual
national security because that's absurd
and it's a distraction from the looming
threat from the east obviously but the
question is how does someone like steele
who's a buffoon not even an american
citizen have the power to influence our
political system so completely
kash patel lived this he's a former
white house intel committee national
security adviser devin nunes is ranking
member of the house intel committee he
was the chairman republicans controlled
the house they've spent years on this
dossier they both join us tonight thank
you both very much for coming on cash to
you first so christopher steele i would
assume since you know an awful lot about
the details in this dossier you believe
owes the world a groveling apology not
to put words in your mouth
an apology would be starters thanks for
having us tucker look devin nunes was uh
strong enough to lead the charge that
unearthed the false allegations in the
dossier that the hillary campaign paid
for it more fraudulently crooks like
lisa page and peter strzok coupled with
christopher steele ran a false
investigation into trump for 14 months
not just one fisa application four fisa
applications and this guy now start lit
the world on fire and he now wants an us
to apologize to him for misleading
millions of americans i think that is
the height of hypocrisy and that is why
people hate the fbi uh so much including
christopher steele as its greatest
source in the last 20 years yeah that's
for sure
congressman nunes i mean one of the
effects of the russia hoax was to
prevent the last administration from
cleaning house in the permanent
bureaucracy and maybe just to guess you
tell me that's one of the reasons the
so-called intel community in the doj the
second biden took over
were still there in full force to you
know take away the civil liberties of
trump voters
well i would also say tucker that most
of the people that were involved in the
so-called p-tape and the dossier got
promotions
by the biden administration so they were
resurrected old obama people but you
know furthermore you have to remember
it's still himself who was actually
working for russians okay in the past
and what did he do he interfered in our
election the very thing he said he's
claiming in this documentary that he was
trying to protect he's some kind of
patriot it's just it's it's comical
well it is comical
tell i wonder can you think of anybody
so here you have a history changing lie
this is not just the earth is flat kind
of thing but this was a lie with the
purpose to hamstring
a democratic elected administration has
anybody ever been held accountable for
this that you're aware of
no not internally at the fbi but i hope
john durham's on the march to to secure
indictments against look christopher
steele and the fbi knew from jump that
the information was bogus they fed it to
a court anyway and they lied about it in
the media and possibly leaked classified
information this guy is no hero he is no
james bond he's inspector gadget on
sudafed and now he's crying for the
world to love him let's not forget the
lives he wrecked along the way of
american citizens and the likes of
myself and devin nunes because we
exposed it he came after us along with
the fake news media and we're fighting
on
that's for sure and i wish you more time
because both of you guys suffered
personally i hope you will come back to
explain how your own lives changed in
the middle of all this because i know
that they did cash patel dev nunes thank
you both
thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else